okay
welcome to our live stream for this
morning
um doing a design review of code
assistance
and this is something we are building
for the upcoming version of wolfram
language
and let's take a look at what we've got
here
okay where do we okay so um
small update here i i don't i don't have
anything implemented or to show yet but
there's i've been thinking about the
design
and i wasn't even really totally happy
with my design i was less happy with the
changes you asked in my design although
i thought
i understood why you wanted to make such
changes
and so i wanted to pitch uh a
variant of the idea here and maybe just
to remind yourself bring up the
the futurized documentation for box
ready
so the the sticky issue here was
the the notion that it's returning an
association
and the reason for doing the so is to
so that we can have a hash that we can
double check
and make sure that things aren't
changing when you do
other operations um in this case the
operation i was targeting was box
extract but really it's not the only one
i mean you know notebook right
you know as a similar sort of operation
you don't want to know what's this
supposed to return in general
well so i mean in general uh
box read is something that is is kind of
a it's
it's a close cousin of of notebook read
um but uh what is what it's doing is
it's taking boxes what what's the
difference between
written from boxes or to expression
this doesn't have anything to do with uh
two expression or two boxes this is
dealing with what's in the notebook
it's it's it's much closer to notebook
read than anything else
so what is the handle that it has that
says this is what is the
dom handle effectively to the boxes
well so it you start with a
cell object or a box object and
part of the issue is that uh
unless you can attach yourself to like a
dynamic box or a dynamic module box
there isn't really a good way to get
a box object if you're in one of those
you can
you know evaluate evaluation box and get
a box object
but if you're i mean you know
particularly like in the
code assistant context uh you know
that's
really not going to be a thing that you
can count on you want to be able to
you know look at the entire structure of
just like normal row boxes and basic
boxes that kind of thing
and then be able to get objects from
those
and so that's where box extract comes in
the idea is box read
allows you to read
you know to read the boxes determine
which things you're interested in
by part specification and then
use those parts pass those parts
specifications to box extract which will
give you box objects then
and then having those box objects you
can then change them using notebook
right
so that's the basic idea but by having a
box object you mean you have some kind
of pointer handle type yes
yes and it means you don't have to for
example fiddle with selections anymore
because you have a stable handle to the
thing you don't have to change your and
that's using uuids of some kind
um not at present it will in the future
but that's an implementation detail
that's not
too relevant for what for the immediate
decision let me understand the workflow
here so
if i want to if i take a box let's say
the box that represents the section
heading
uh that's actually not a box
that's in the text data world text data
is in boxes
um so all right i'm gonna create a box
somewhere
this this is right i mean dollar versus
box
yes the string is a box et cetera okay
all right so now what do i do now
um so um what you do have
is you do have handles to the cells
that's easy to get
well just evaluate cells bracket bracket
right okay i mean this by the way could
be better done
this could be and and sells takes
options that allows you to kind of you
know
sift through fairly and right so i i
would like to say that this was built a
long time ago
and and i think these this you know
these blobs should be more expressive
that's which is fine i'm not
i'm not worried about taking time for
that discussion right now but i'm not
opposed
okay okay fine all right now what do i
do
okay so i mean nothing is implemented
right now but in principle
you might do for example box read of
that first cell object
uh and um
in in this case it's a trivial box i
mean it's it's okay fine but then what
would that
uh so that would return uh
boxes uh which you could
basically determine you know if it were
a nested thing you could figure out
the part spec uh and brenton is already
doing this actually
so uh i mean brenton is his parser is
working with part specs so this is a
very natural fit
i don't understand what you mean by i
mean what is this thing
that first cell object how do i how do i
get the cell
for that how do i get the actual raw
content the payload
well and so i mean right now you can do
notebook read and notebook read is a
thing that actually works right now so
just do notebook read of
yeah there you go now box read would
just be giving you the boxes not all the
cell stuff around it
okay all right um and so for example
you know i mean it would give me the
contents the box data or it would give
me the contents dollar version yeah uh
right the stuff inside of box data so
like in the third
example it would give you the row box
the row box would be the head
oops all right so then here
if i say now how do i get the cells for
for percent five um
the uh just to
say last of cells of cell style arrow
outputs
ethan our live stream is saying at least
twice here cells should take
pattern match conditions do we
understand what that means
um oh you the cell's function
should take an ability to to match to a
pattern
i think that would be difficult but yeah
so now you can
no yeah notebook read that
okay there you go um okay but that's got
a cell wrapper around it i see so this
one but what you would get
is it would start with the robots
um
okay yeah and and so then
you know let's say i don't know for some
reason you were interested
in uh you know
in the first fraction box you know then
you would get a part
spec of uh what is it uh
um uh one comma
three what do you mean i would get that
spec how would i guess well
well i mean that's a thing you would so
if you're interested in a specific box
you're going to have to
use wolfram language to figure out where
it is in this
expression you're not going to be able
to avoid that that's what ethan is
talking about pattern matching that it's
yeah there's a there's an issue okay so
fine box read
i mean we can imagine some box cases
type thing
but but so let's so let's say what you
really wanted was that first fraction
box
yeah you wanted a box object pointing to
that first fraction box
so um the what box extract does
is it takes you know the same thing that
box read does
but with a part spec and in this case
the part spec would be what uh
whatever it is one comma two or whatever
it is and then it would return the
corresponding box objects
um okay all right so what
um so and and and this will allow
brenton to do everything that he needs
to do and it will allow a number of
other
expressive you know box level operations
but
you were talking about something to do
with being able to write stuff back and
so on
yes so here's the issue because these
things can happen
you know side by side with you know the
user typing in stuff
or you know some other program and some
other kernel modifying the notebook
and you have a potential race condition
situation here
uh-huh and and you don't want to corrupt
the notebook because you know the user
was sure
right so what do you do yes so that's
what
my association and crypto hash
was dealing with yes um you
weren't a huge fan of that and i have to
say i wasn't the hugest fan of it either
so here's my alternative
my alternative is basically uh
something like uh check abort
um that basically keeps track of you
know
inside of its first argument keeps track
of you know
crypto hashes on read operations and
then
automatically fails any crypto hashes of
you know modifying operations sorry
automatically fails any modifying
operations that the crypto hashes don't
match
so i mean if you know just look at the
documentation real quick for check abort
and
i i i think the analogy is is fairly
close here
uh but would it be like a transaction
well it would be like it would be like a
transaction that can fail
yeah so everything fails
checkerboard is not everything fails
right well i mean you could also imagine
something like abort protect but the
problem
hold on hold on hold on the thing you're
trying to address is
don't write it if the crypto hash has
changed
right that's right that's exactly right
okay so
so
wait wait wait the it is a complicated
thing here because it's got to be
a handle to it it's not the expression
you didn't extract
and in fact it might be multiple hits
i mean okay fine fine but what you're
saying is
this is saying okay so can you just tell
me what what is the fragment of code
that does the right
um so in
in in this case in the loop that i'm
talking
about there are actually two sorts of
fragments that
uh that need to be protected in this way
one is the box extract uh
because you know you know the box read
and box extract
the whole idea is they're matched up to
one another if things change the box
the part spec that you pass the box
extract is meaningless
so that's um okay
and and then the second is the notebook
write operation
okay how does this relate to cleanly
i have never heard of cleanly so i have
no idea
cleanly i think that's the name we've
we've settled on
is the name for with with local settings
so cleanly has an init
it has a an expert and has a cleanup
so let me just say i could
use say the abort protect model
uh where we just prevent any changes
from happening
but i'm not a fan of that because that's
gonna no
no yeah
exactly exactly i i would much rather
the operation fail than we stop the user
from being able to type
so okay okay
okay so hold on hold on what you want
okay so what you want is i mean this is
unfortunate this is
closely related to christopher's whole
confirm and close mechanism
right do you understand that mechanism
uh i'm only vaguely aware of it okay so
basically what it does is
there's an enclosing in close and you
put in your piece of code there's blah
blah blah blah blah code here blah blah
blah blah blah
there's a family of confirm functions is
this kind of a design by contract sort
of thing
i think so but it but basically what
confirm does is you return a value here
okay let's say it's one over x and it
might be one over zero
if that is uh that might be you might
say confirm message or confirm
you could say confirm buy
and then you could say you know number q
yeah
okay if that fails it essentially aborts
and it goes to the nearest and closing
in close
okay and that encloses them past some
association and i don't know what it
returns something by default some kind
of failure object by default
okay all right so let's let's walk
through this because
this is what you want to have happen
here
is that your read
your operations okay first
point is basically anything that gets
read
should be crypto hash for the remainder
crypto has checked for the remainder of
the transaction
right i understand
but if it doesn't get read don't care
you know if there's other parts of the
notebook that change i want to allow
them to change and not work no no i
understand that i understand
that so what you want is that it's like
a critical section type thing much like
cleanly
yes yeah it's it it is
it is like a critical section but one
that you can back out of
whether you're one one that can fail
instead of instead of blocking it just
fails
right it doesn't do the operation yeah
right
so so what this is is
and in answer to tom's question um
we can't do all the right operations
atomically but what we can do is
we can use the
you know tie into the undo mechanism to
back out of things that we've partially
done
um that's good
okay so wait a minute what is the handle
that you are basically
i mean so what you're saying is okay
this is a tricky design thing and
okay okay hold on let me think for a
second okay so what you want to do
is within this section
any returned notebook object
notebook handle should be crypto hashed
and yeah
notebook object cell object uh
or box object yeah
yeah anything that went through a read
operation
anything that you called notebook read
box read
options current value um
you know any sort of reading operation
right so what you essentially want is
some kind of notebook block type thing
yes well i thought of the name notebook
block
but i i didn't think block was quite the
right name but that's
definitely the idea right so
but now what this is doing is it's
implicitly looking at any
is it a block thing or is it is it
dynamic or is it lexical
no it can be anything that is evaluated
during
the sub-evaluation of this expression
here
right is to be considered
something that
let me think about this for a second
that will cause
the notebook to be put back so wait a
minute
the actions are supposed to fail so
these actions
are not necessarily so so inside
notebook block
you might be writing back into the
notebook you might be trying to write
back into the notebook
but that would fail if the thing if
anything to do with what you're writing
to
has changed according to the crypto hash
has changed since you've read it
yeah i mean if you're doing blind rights
you know if you didn't read anything and
you're just writing blindly of course
of course that we're not going to check
i mean what you know it's the round trip
that matters
all right so look i think roughly this
notebook block concept is the right
thing and we simply say that anything
evaluated within the notebook block
has the feature that it is um
um
[Music]
okay so anything evaluated within there
has the feature that it fails
i don't think it's right well this is
why i like check abort because we want
to
fail expression or you know
some way to i mean well i mean we could
use a confirm mechanism
um okay and that that i i just can't
speak to
right but what confirm does is it is
using internally the throw catch abort
mechanism
okay okay it just it just paints lexical
things all over the place to make it
more controlled and so on okay um
okay so this mechanism is confirm
see the question is whether you wrap the
individual rights or whether you want a
whole code block that has this feature
uh yes i agree i mean yes you might be
around i mean you might doing be doing
round trips on
five individual operations do you want
to group them together
or do you want five individual blocks
this is a complicated design question do
we have to solve this right now
well um you know i could put together
something that brenton could start
working with uh
you know pretty quickly without this but
it would not be something i would want
to see go into production because of
you know the potential for corruption
yeah i understand so i mean but it's
okay we can it'll be an ex
you know but it would but it would be
enough to play with so
you know the box read box extract you
know
with no crypto hashing no associations
no
none of that stuff that that i think i
could do pretty quickly
okay and like i said it actually maps
very well into brenton's uh current
parsing mechanism
okay so the notebook block outside of
those things
would fundamentally its semantics would
be
that if
something goes wrong would it continue
executing the expression
using old values of the reads or what it
would it
abort out um
well i mean the point is that you're
producing
side effects which is changes in the
notebook uh
so you want to stop doing that and and
potentially revert to anything but i
understand but but if you did that
or you want to revert well so this is
the question that tom brought up
uh which is that okay this is a
complicated design issue we're not going
to solve this right now we need a custom
meeting just to talk about this
okay but but i mean if if you
think notebook block is a decent
starting
name it's a different starting point but
i don't think it's that right well well
then i can
i can put together a document that we
can review
with but my suggestion is that this
mechanism
of you know
this mechanism reminds me a lot of like
input fields where you can type whatever
you want
but there's some moment of commitment
yes
when the thing you know does what it
does
yes yes and i think there's a more
general mechanism here
for what the you know
this moment of commitment after which
i i'm not quite understanding it here
there's things where you're kind of
making lightweight changes to the
notebook
but where nothing look it's a causal
dependency issue
that is what depended on that
lightweight change that you made
did something did did the outside world
change as a result of that as it did you
can't back out of it
you see what i'm saying in other words
if you made a change to some box
and some other function was called on
that that had an
external effect then it's absolutely
ridiculous to back out of that box
change
right um
sorry if you made a change to a box yeah
you made a change to a box
and something in the function inside
notebook block
had an external effect consequent on the
change you made to the box
then backing out that change to the box
you mean before well there won't be any
problem
if the function tries to make a change
afterwards because it will
preemptively detect i know i know that i
know that i'm saying
i'm saying look this is the question
it's like a transaction
right yes and you know what is atomic
what is not
i don't think it's the right thing to
try and atomize
i don't think it's going to work to have
both
you can type whatever you want and the
transactions are atomic
okay in other words because what's going
to happen is the thing i just described
actually this is really
close to exactly how the undo system
works
uh because the the undo system has
transactions
that do not necessarily represent
sequential operations in time
uh the undo understands that you know
there is a transaction which is all of
the operations which were produced
by click by clicking a button
uh and that this could be a sequence of
operations
which might have been interleaved with
say the operation of uh
you know getting a actually one that
gets interrupted quite often
uh in in undo is returning
multiple cells from a shift enter
evaluation
uh i mean i mean undo is is i i would
love it if undo worked better
i mean i still it's it's hit rate for me
is about 50
well so undo has one big hole in it
which is
which is that it doesn't deal with
styles well and some of the stuff that
you do
uh you know either has to do with that
or people have actually
turned off in your systems because
because they had concerns about those
issues that that is
that's something we should listen we
should put this on our main project list
to enhance it but did you hear what i
said i
we should add yes um
okay but but you know there's um
you know things like you know if you do
uh
oh you know i don't know you know pause
one print of x you know wrapping a door
table around it
you know undo and uh understands you
know
all of those outputs single transactions
i get it
right even if you're typing in the
middle this is a longer discussion okay
transaction based notebook changes well
so
let me just summarize then the short
term plan uh i will implement
a basic box read and box extract that
doesn't do anything with crypto hashing
uh and hand that hand that off to
uh to brenton okay and i will write up a
proposed notebook block
that we can then review in a future
meeting okay not be for 12 too
right okay that's fine okay let me
address a few issues
points from the live stream and then
let's go on with this we're gonna run
out of time here
um sorry i didn't realize that was gonna
take so long
right uh ethan is saying he has very
large notebooks full of notes
searching is way too slow is there a way
to index notebooks
yes text search is supposed to work on
on on notebooks right
does that already work um
i cannot answer that question that's not
my area
i would recommend trying to make an
index and use text search
what what what i can say though is that
uh in our roadmap is
um really a kind of
gut and rethink of uh find um
and that would have some built-in
indexing in the front end
okay but i think text search has a good
chance to work and if it doesn't we'd
like to know
and is who's playing is it devon yep i'm
here
okay so can you um uh that that's an
issue which i
was supposed to have been dealt with
that's a um
um uh nicolas l
issue and the people dealing with the
search stuff
can you check into that please yes i
think that was done but i'm not sure
um ah let's see
lucas is commenting not exactly on topic
but some things that will be helpful
the ability to move boxes in the front
and the ability to insert boxes into
lists eg in a grid
so this is functionality which can be
built
on top of the stuff that we're talking
about it's it's difficult to build the
things that he's talking about without
having some of the fundamentals in place
first
um okay and the fundamentals is what
we've been talking about okay
and nick here is talking about dynamic
of box read
will that work um
well dynamic of notebook read frankly
is is uh problematic
um it seems hard to get dynamic to work
i mean that seems like a
yeah it's it it is uh
this is it it's it oh yeah and and it's
not just notebooks
it's like you know dynamic of get
you know or yeah yeah right right right
right yeah okay listen we have to move
on here
okay package editor toolbar button what
is this
is this in open yeah click on that
so there's a new there's a format cell
button okay have i got some sample code
that i can play with here
uh i mean not no in other words no
okay so i'll find some
um
all right let's take some good and
grotesque code here
okay now what do i do yeah
well i mean first uh remember what this
looks like before
visually and then and then click on the
format cell button
do you have to have the cell selected oh
yeah i guess if you don't have anything
selected it wouldn't work but yeah
um and so you can see it yep
uh in the left hand so first of all
formatting selected cell should have a
capital f
sorry you understand formatting selected
cell down here in the toolbar
in this step sorry yeah should have a
capital f
okay now what did it do
you should be able to hit undo now to
see i don't want to do that i'm gonna
i'm gonna
show it in a different window
for apples to apples it yeah i
i should get a different package window
yeah
i don't see any difference really
i do i see the weird comma here which it
doesn't really help me very much
so this is um it
looks like this is in the input cell yes
i'm sorry i said it again
codes out so this
okay what should i do to make this
useful
well what code you're i mean you're
getting
okay what do i do i've got a big lump of
code tell me what to do
to see your thing actually working i
start a code cell i thought when i copy
pasted it in here i would get a code
cell i'm not sure why you didn't
actually oh you must have copied from
another notebook i guess
that's it i'm gonna take this and i'm
gonna paste it
the content there okay so now i've got
some grotesque code cell
okay yeah okay now i
select that and i say format cell
it says a hundred percent why isn't it
done if it's saying a hundred percent
it take notebook notebook right
takes it i mean i don't know oh yeah
well fine so but can't you get rid of
that once it's done you there's no point
in saying a hundred percent just get rid
of the
notifier when it's done am i making
sense
okay now what am i supposed to see here
i thought we supposed to be having these
various airiness parameters and things
visible here
right that's what this does last time
yep and if you open up
go to the palettes menu
that wasn't what we discussed we
discussed having it here
right so um if
and that's what we discussed nothing
else is not what we discussed so there's
a bug
there's a bug in the front end that's
preventing attached cells from working
in that situation
there in the way and make it a pellet
that's openable from that toolbar
am i making sense what where is this
code form
what am i looking for here the first the
code formatter
okay so what you should do if that
doesn't work right is at the very least
this palette should be openable
do you understand what i'm saying well
are you how do you want it presented in
the toolbar there
well what was what was the way it's
supposed to work
i'm asking well you no no no no no what
was the way it was supposed to work when
the bug wasn't there
you know a drop down menu presumably
looking like the functions and sections
uh buttons you know on the left there
yeah so i don't understand so you're
saying in here
okay did we have ux for this or not
yes okay what was the ux
what we're what i'm saying right now a
drop down menu
okay be specific so this was so what it
was
was if here we say that doesn't seem to
have
a um okay so let me put in a heading
why doesn't that have something for
sections now
why doesn't that uh update
it it doesn't update in real time so all
right okay fine
okay so i don't understand what that ux
is supposed to be
so i took a look at the ux on this and
um
it's it's not just the drop down menu
like the other buttons
um it's a button sort of split
uh with you know with the end split off
but it's a separate down thing so you
can either click on format cell
or you can click on the right hand side
of it which pops an attached cell
with that code formatter palette in it
but there's a bug in the front end at
the moment
which prevents attached cells working
properly
with duct cells so we couldn't do that
is that difficult to fix or is that um
john
so i i i didn't realize this was a
discussion that we were having
uh i i think i wasn't in the loop or
wasn't paying attention but
yeah it's not so easy to deal with
because doc cells on some systems are
like
separate views that just clip at their
edges
um so it's
well where would you want this thing to
fit to pop up anyway
no what was the idea for in the case
where you press that button
what is the where would the pop-up go so
it would just be um like literally if
you to drag you know that that that
palette
underneath that that button uh with a
little kind of you know those little
carrots at the top
um to sort of say you know it's come
from from that cell
right essentially like that i see
okay and we can't do this right now
because the because the
docked cell is its own thing is that
basically
yeah yeah i mean it you could kind of
emulate it with a weird floating window
but it would look
all right i've got an idea here okay so
i think what we should do
right now is this should be reformatted
to be another layer of toolbar
okay and if you open it just like the
tools menu
now that now that definitely can be done
if you want to expand the toolbar
temporarily that's not a problem
right so that's what i'm suggesting so
i'm suggesting the mechanism
would be very much like what happens in
the tools submenu
right you know what i'm talking about
right in um
uh right in here right
oh what's it doing oh don't crash please
okay
there we go all right so in here see
this tools submenu
i don't know why this isn't working but
you know what i'm talking about right
that tools menu opens or closes nowhere
you get what i'm saying
i understand yeah so i think what we
should do is we should have
format cell as soon as you press it
it could even produce this control bar
down here that can contains these
elements
in a horizontal format suitable you know
okay makes sense i think we could we
should we should still keep the button
split
in two and if you click format cell it
formats it performs the action
and opens that and then if you obviously
if you click the arrow it just opens
that
fine fine and then and then that that
open
thing determines is the set of settings
um that determine what
the uh code formatting will be like
yes it's the contents of the code
formatter palette essentially
right right it would be just this just
just
done horizontally okay so now if i go
here
and i go i de-errify this how do i how
do i actually make it take action
well you wanted the airiness slider to
be interactive so it is
um so if yeah if you crank it all the
way to the left or right you should see
changes um
i like those that iconography for the
airiness
yeah no yeah so it took i should put
progress
in for when it's doing that also but
yeah it so it took that long
well i guess that's a huge sell
if it had been multiple cells would it
have been okay so this is cool
okay so that's that airiness um
okay and then if i go down here
i wait to whatever appropriately long
yep
cool let's look let's just see how what
this
looks like
why doesn't the multi-click work here
okay there we go let's do that one okay
so now i'm going to do that
and that's a smaller cell obviously
and you can just have the cursor you
don't have to select a cell bracket
this is way too slow this is way too
slow come on this is a tiny cell
why is it taking so long what is it
doing
oh this is too slow
and that was a big jump in airiness what
do we
do we understand the linearity or
non-linearity of airiness
yes so whatever that is right around
point seven whatever that value is where
that
inflection is um basically it starts
putting new lines
in between all square brackets and then
you know just
everything just expands uh uh hold on
hold on is
airiness a continuous parameter
no so you have
break points in the airiness is that
correct
yes okay i don't think it's a great
thing to have a slider then especially
given that it's so damn slow
i mean i think it'd be better to just
have some settings
particularly given that it's so slow
there are a lot of them though
no no i understand but but you could
just have a bunch of buttons
that illustrate you know you could use
noah's iconography here
and just have five buttons or something
that go click click click click click
and then you can select i think it might
be better anyway because you might sort
of remember
i want a four out of five airiness
look the idea that the the slider is
going to work is just it's just cruddy
right now it's cruddy it's too slow
it's not right to set up the idea that
it's a slider
okay well and
you know i i think maybe it should be on
the table maybe it shouldn't be a slider
i mean i don't know what i'm just saying
yeah if it's six positions maybe we
should
show six positions that's what i think
we should do i think what we should do
is use noah's iconography idea here
to show six little buttons that go from
the
really clumped to the really unclumped
by the way it it could also be
a slider with marked intervals yeah i
understand that but i don't want a
slider
i don't want to slide it well well no no
i i'm saying that a slider
you know that has the intervals marked
you know
it's it's you know you know it's
discrete
and you know what the levels of
discreteness are
say again what no i just said that that
was actually the original design to put
um
ticks on it on the slider
yeah okay but i think i agree actually
that buttons are better
the row of discrete buttons i think
would be fine let's try it
and then and then i mean particularly
then they don't actually have to be in a
linear sequence you know if it turns out
that
that we that there are different two
different branches of what airiness
means
we have at least some chance to
represent that
um
it's really slow though why is it so
slow
um i'd have to profile it to say for
sure
okay well it needs to be significantly
faster this is really kind of
pathetically slow
right in terms of front end operations
it's just a single read and a single
right
correct yeah yeah so that shouldn't
be an issue okay so so let me comment on
this for a second so
there's a parameter which is basically
given an
average piece of code what is its height
as a function of airiness
you see what i'm saying so you know
physics silly
i suspect there's some kind of phase
transition as a function of what you
know you continuously change some
binding amount
and then it's going to discontinuously
change its height i suspect
because i think things will will kind of
back up at some point and it'll just
stop
you know really expanding so i think we
somebody should do a little bit of
analysis of that
in other words as if there is a yeah you
get what i'm saying
because i also think and possibly this
can be reflected in the iconography in
some way i don't know if it can
this idea that it's going to get longer
that's kind of obvious
never mind um
right okay
okay so let's take a look at um
so if i go to tab width 2 and i say
format selected cell
i can't see a difference there's no
difference what did it do
things they did change they you can hit
undo and you can
yeah i mean if you do you can see the
difference
okay
what about in a in a standard input cell
can i apply this stuff because i don't
want to just beat things and code cells
what do i do in a just an ordinary thing
here like this
can i apply this in here yep
oh cool
so freaking slow it's just so insanely
slow
just insanely slow and why isn't this
going back now
well i mean you're it's give it time to
catch up yeah
okay you have got to figure out how to
make this faster this is
sure really outrageously seen faster
than this brenton i i i think
yeah well part of this it also might be
something to do with dynamics
i'm not you know i'm not i'm not
completely sure yet
okay that will be helped by having
buttons you don't have to have some
continuous action dynamic
true true yep just a button
and i it's it's it's possible in the
current
in your current implementation maybe uh
you're getting called twice
when you expect to only be called once i
i could see that happening
yeah okay fine all right i get it this
is
okay so this how are we going to provide
this so in the notebook toolbar this
will be something that's available
otherwise how do you do this how do i
apply this to a generic notebook
if the thing is only available in the
package editor toolbar i mean through
the palette would be is the only other
option
no no no no no there isn't a palette
right because it's in the toolbar here
right
well i mean you know we can talk about
the
toolbar for regular notebooks but that's
a much bigger question as you know
all right well so for this version i
guess we put it in this palette
in this palettes menu okay
and what's it called it's not called
code formatter
it's called probably
well code space formatting
okay that's what it should be called in
this menu
and we should move it to a place of
better prominence
um but not here because this is this
is this is user added stuff right yeah
and that's just because
brenton didn't know and i didn't have a
chance to review it and tell him uh
that's good that's fine easy to fix okay
um
code formatting goes in there and um
for now uh and then in this case it
becomes part of the toolbar
when the notebook toolbar is ready it
will become part of
something callable from from the toolbar
right yep
um
okay and we could put we could
potentially add to this palette some
extra
things um
okay there are comments
from ethan about
bulk indent and d indent
it's on the list yep code folding
and collapsing we're well aware of that
that's okay yeah
i mean actually some of this is more in
my camp than
brenton's i don't know that but it's
we're still
trying to catch up on the other things
yeah
um yeah
ethan is saying needs to be smarter with
saving space
and fix operators
ha changing functions with brackets to
add signs
yeah i'm not the formatter is never
going to it's not going to do that
it's not going to do that you don't need
to yeah it's not going to do that
minifying was in a different meeting and
that's what that would be
yeah multi-line tab indent
that's interesting select multiple lines
hit tab
yeah yeah it's a standard editor feature
it's
definitely in in the list of things to
do
okay all right let's go back to the
agenda
except curiously uh what is it xcode
where it's not
i if i recall correctly where it's not
tab um
it's something else
but everyone else thinks he's tapped so
okay 70 good well we're we're
modernizing
yeah um rob
quoting rob knapp we're not using
fortran anymore
oh well good he's he's only modernized
quite recently i think
so um okay i'm fine with 80.
so long as it works with email clients
um well because i think that's a bigger
question too of what even what is it
what's an and what's an email client
right now in the 21st century you know
if we don't mean a web interface where
it's not going to you know
break lines anyway or i don't know
does somebody know they are okay does
anybody in this meeting know the answer
to this
oh the question is is it the case that
we have hard line breaks
right given that we have hard line
breaks
you know any system if you make the
window narrow enough is going to fail
with hard line breaks because it's got
to wrap the wrap the line and then it'll
have the hard line break
right yeah
okay and then and this is why you know
copy paste
has the conservative line with that it
does but i don't think that the
the what we do for copy paste needs to
be reflected in the formatting i don't
think the two
need to be connected at all but i mean
but so if i if i make my
email client narrow enough you're saying
i mean what's going to happen if i have
something with hardline breaks
um that i mean you could split
you could end up splitting someplace
that changes the interpretation
okay so here where do i have something
with hardline
for example for example it could uh
break inside of a string thereby adding
a new line inside of the string
okay so this is something with hard line
breaks
and i've now so it looks pretty ugly
right
we but but that's those line breaks
don't matter
yeah those are soft i understand these
are soft line bricks just looks ugly
yeah so there's nothing to do about that
no i understand but as i go wide
what are you telling me
well that's this answers the question if
this particular
male in on os x doesn't insert hard line
breaks
then there's no problem apple mail
communicating with apple mail
is generally fine yeah but your your
issue is
that another mail client upon
sending the mail could insert a hard
line break like thunderbird
okay so
you know i i use a a uh on windows i use
a male client
uh called postbox which is a thunderbird
derivative so
i think i'm what i'm about to say
applies to thunderbird it definitely
applies to postbox if you run it in
plain text mode
which i do then yeah it introduces
hard line breaks um where how many
characters after
i don't remember what the default is but
it's it's like 75-ish 80-ish something
like that
uh i'll have to oh god what a mess
okay so let's let's summarize what the
story is here
we're saying we will insert hard line
breaks
at character n which right now is set to
17 you're pushing to change it to 80.
if this is inserted into a mailer it
will insert hard line breaks
at some other character n prime
which might be smaller than the one
we're using if it is smaller than the
one we're using
the code is mushed up right
okay so but no mailer
the question is you know
look the thing we need to know is what
is the lie is there a line break
is there a standard in the you know
whatever it is the what what is that
thing called the
the um it's not the mimes yeah the rfc
for mail it's not the mime one it's some
other one what is the one that
determines
the standard for what you send through
smtp or whatever else
well i don't know but john john said
earlier i mean we're
we're conflating two different things
that don't have to be you know what code
looks like as you're editing it
doesn't have to be what code looks like
when you're copying and pasting it into
an
email editor an email client
and and and likewise i you know i think
that people
who were dealing with uh
uh you know with code cells or with
uh text editors are you know kind of
have a higher threshold of pain
than people who are you know just using
the front end default mode
input cells and i just want stuff to
work sort of thing
um all right okay so look
most people on a live stream are saying
there should be a setting for what this
what what this um uh hard line width
wrapping thing is and that could be a
setting that's part of that
format i don't think anyone disagrees
with that okay fine
all right next um
uh question about are we going to add
line numbering don't we have a line
numbering option
um so that is something that's going to
have to
go in the front end and it is on my
roadmap
um okay
i mean and and it's and it's it's it's
it's going to be a little strange
because
you know some blank lines uh turn into
cell breaks so
you know i have to think a little bit
about exactly how that works but
it should work i agree and um
and it is on my roadmap okay a comment
from
rbs i can't read these things rb i'm
going to call
this person uh quoting rfc
5322 section 2.1.1
uh says a line of characters in your
email must not exceed 998 characters but
should not be more than 78 characters
excluding the crlf
uh thank you uh this is why i love open
meetings like this
right okay so the answer is what this
is saying and we should look at it more
carefully is 78 characters
seems to be a critical number sure sure
so if that's correct and we should
validate that
that's correct then we should set it to
78.
okay two characters are not going to
kill anybody and it's going to save a
bunch of stuff
okay thank you um
all right
yeah so in the previous meeting um you
were talking about unifying the clouds
line breaking and um the formatter
packages uh
line breaking and um
[Music]
talking with yawn more from cloud group
about what it does learning that it's
breaking on pixels and so that relates
to
deeper questions about the future of the
formatter and i didn't know if yon if
he was still here or not um if he wanted
to john
can you come on cloud the cloud line
breaker
yeah i mean i'm not sure what i should
really comment on but the
our line breaker is very similar to the
one in nb lite
and in spirit certainly to what the
desktop runner does
i think it's fairly different from
this sort of character-based
uh code formatter but
you know i mean but that's you know
designed for input cells which is fine
for code cells
you know it's we you know there are a
different set of assumptions
for code cells where uh a character
based line breaking is not
a hundred percent perfect but it's much
better than for input cells
um sorry i got distracted here um
well okay so
okay what is the main point here the
main point is
i'm i'm very confused well just the
point is in the future
so the code formatter package that i've
been working on has no concept
of you know pixels or m's or points or
anything you know
it's characters um that's not saying
that it cannot
learn about these things for example a a
a
a non-fixed-width character so what
you're saying is
if there was a super wide character
you wouldn't care about that you you you
are just it's like
like currently yes correct yeah
and i think that's perfectly fine but
what yarn is saying is that what he's
doing
is to break see this is the difference
between
what you want for code where you're more
interested
in having a reproducible line break
and what you want for text where you're
more interested in having the thing look
sensible
yes and i don't know what i don't know
if there's only the two camps either
because you know
fraction box and graphics box as input
you know boxes let's say
what does that mean um how do you
format those in the future there
there's also a separate issue which you
could potentially deal with
uh which is combining characters unicode
yes i understand well that oh god i
don't even wanna
yeah true yeah but but but but dealing
with it you could
deal with that in a kind of
character-based way but you need to know
you know how many code points is a glyph
um yes and that's not to say yeah i'm
not even yeah yeah
yeah yeah all all all potential problems
yeah yeah
yeah i mean it gets much crazier
all kinds of ridiculous things can
happen yeah so not that that's almost
like stepping off the
i don't think we should do that i think
it should be character-based i think
that's the way to make it reproducible
now
what yarn is saying is that his
formatter
for input cells is what we're talking
about right john
any cell really right
is doing wrapping which is also what the
front end is doing
generically right it's doing wrapping
based on i mean if i take a piece of
code here
um not in
if i just take that random big blob of
code it's rather horrible code here
um well i mean i mean this this very
cell is already doing it
i mean if you you know if you narrow the
window it's already doing it
right so here this will
be breaking based on the actual width i
mean if i made this and not let me just
do that for the hell of it
let me make this a non-fixed width font
how would i do that what's the best
known fixed font i can just go um i'll
just
i can make it into text or well
it just actually no no don't make a text
uh do command
command t and then change the font to
whatever um and the comic sense is the
best one to answer your question
yes yeah let's do it
oh my gosh oh yeah yeah there is that
that's non-fixed width right
correct okay it looks rather nice
actually
that was what we can don't get any ideas
i like the association operator looking
how they look well with that
that will we're working on programming
ligatures that will cover
that sort of thing so okay wait so
that's not
okay fine never mind okay anyway but but
the main point is that this the wrapping
here
is determined by actual character width
as opposed to
just number of characters whereas what
you're saying which is exactly the right
thing
yes whereas the previous meeting you
were expressing
the desire to have these you know the
cloud form the line breaker
be unified with what i'm doing
um and i'm wrong okay no no no no just
it's not a
you know it's not a day's worth of work
you know no i understand that but i
think i'm actually wrong because i think
this is yeah
well i mean unification is definitely
wrong whether
whether you want to have something that
does something
like this i don't know maybe or maybe
not but the notion that you could unify
with what the cloud is
actually doing that's that is wrong
well but there are there are other
questions
i mean there is value
in being able to talk about this stuff
programmatically
well i i mean being able to you know
yeah i i'm not saying there aren't
features here that might not be
interesting i'm just saying that yeah
you know at best you're you know you
would be consuming the services of the
cloud or
of the front end uh to uh you know
to get with information that you need
okay
yeah because that was like the main the
the last point the last
possibility well yeah fine yep okay all
right
uh just uh the various comments on our
live stream about
about um uh basically getting
a um sort of decisions about best
practices for code formatting
and i i know we want to do this we've
we've tried to do this but it's really
complicated
and i think most likely what we should
do sometime
maybe we should do this at the
technology conference actually that'd be
an interesting idea
that's a good session for the danielle
will be upset that i'm suggesting a new
thing but we could have a
a um a little um focus group
and talk about uh
formatting conventions and perhaps what
we could do
i mean i think the most likely thing you
know i
i had boldly suggested that we should
just
dictate a convention and like it or
leave it
but that was that's been shouted down
predictably from a number of fronts
okay so what i think is a better idea is
i don't think we're gonna get that you
know i know we're gonna get it i know
that
various people you know who i know whose
code looks pretty nice
right and and also you know
i suspect it's going to be you know it's
it's like somebody's saying
uh there should only be one style of
clothes i think that's happened in
various
periods in history in various countries
but but you know
um basically people don't typically like
it
um and i suspect what will be better is
to
have a you know
named potentially named styles
of formatting that people can define
and that we will you know just like
style sheets we'll have
you know some number of them that our
people can use by default
and then other people can introduce ones
with with
complicated parameter settings that
potentially can become popular
as you know a community type issue but i
think what we have to do to make that
possible is to have all this
all the parameterization of code
formatting straightened out
um yeah i mean it's a lot of work um i
was just going to say for the tech
conference
i'm giving a talk about the formatter i
guess i'm advertising myself now but i'm
giving a talk about the formatter but
i'm also going to be
holding a workshop on code tools about
the the linter and the formatter where
i want people to join and to give
i think you'll have it i think you'll
have as much yeah i mean the linter is a
whole
different yeah these are very different
things this is
that that is much more of a the more it
says the happier we are
code formatting is much more you know
it's something where there are real
choices to be made
yeah yeah and so if we had a separate
dedicated session to this
yeah i think it'll be useful so why
don't we suggest this to danielle see if
she can put it in
um the uh
uh comments that um um
harley ruta has developed his own
stylesheet for his intellij
plug-in yes that's interesting um
sandra is asking how would this work
with emojis
that's what i mentioned earlier it's
very much related to the combining
characters problem it's just two
variants of the same thing
um okay let's go back to this
this is an idea of having comments to
switch on enough code formatting
yeah so this is one thing that is needed
wild okay
why well as an example here that i was
giving people
do put tlc into
their code especially with tables and
things uh
you know long digits and you you line
columns
so what you want is a notation
that is a comment a special comment
which is a comment to the code formatter
that says what to do with this piece of
code so in other words what you're
basically doing and i can't imagine that
you want to say code format on and off
i mean i would think what you want to do
i mean i would suggest
that um uh you know the best type of
thing might be something like
i don't know i mean i don't know what
the right symbol is what is the what is
the symbol of the code formatter
there are functions code no no i
understand i understand but i mean
something like
i mean is it a toggle yes i do
actually want to be saying off and on
yeah
no but i'm saying i'm saying what you're
saying is
i'm i'm suggesting that what it looks
like because you don't want a giant
piece of
glob of garbage inside your coats
completely we need to
yeah yeah yeah yeah so oh i see yeah
yeah yeah um some
something like this sure
so it will be a convention for comments
yeah
the um uh
that basically says i want
it's a very weird thing right because i
mean basically a comment
yeah so this is the first case of
something like this in the link you know
okay so hold on hold on let me let me
let me be clear about a couple of things
okay so
in rich formatted text
obviously there are styles that can be
inserted that say to do something with a
particular run of text
right so those styles are inserted as
metadata
not part of the actual uh character
content
of the thing right so for example if i
just take this
this table and i go you know command i
i'll i'll italicate or bold whatever
right
okay so that is something maintained as
metadata
that is not part of the um
so i i would argue well we've now
changed like before
applying that style what we were seeing
visually right here
would have been exactly the same as the
physical bytes in
that dot m dot dot wl file this
is now different than the physical bytes
that would be in that file
i understand i understand that i
understand that so there are a couple of
things that could happen
right so one thing that could happen oh
boy i did this in
like smp oh that's so shocking
um of having comments that that
determined things back in those well
anyway never mind let's not go into that
history
um the you know
what i can imagine is that this is what
would happen visually on the screen you
would have some way
uh possibly from this uh format of thing
of selecting something and it would
change color somehow
to indicate that it is a locked thing
that you have chosen to to work in a
particular way
folding and stuff too yeah right but
then
on serialization it would insert
comments
that are you know that have some some
you know
those comments so in other words that
the code that unlike what happens i mean
clearly underneath the cell
there is a bunch of you know if we look
underneath this cell
right we've already got all possible
tagging information here
right but that's underneath the cell
if i were to just say you know put the
cell out as
text if i were to do a default copy
paste of this cell
it will not contain if i do a default
copy paste to my emailer
of this cell it will by default not
contain anything that says that's bold
well that might understand rich text i'm
not sure but
it doesn't it doesn't that is not the
default the default is to paste it as
plain text
yeah then yeah okay so what we need is
a mechanism which we already have
versions of
where were you to go from this code that
has
locked formatting in it do you see what
i'm saying by locked formatting i mean
you have selected a piece of this you
press the lock formatting button
in in this thing here and it
then causes this to be visually some
color or something like this
whatever it is i don't know exactly how
that will work then
where i to copy paste from this even
though i think i'm doing a plain text
copy paste
upon the the actual thing put on the
clipboard
would contain some kind of comment stuff
that says that that delimits this area
of
of locked formatting does that make
sense
yes what you're saying is the comments
are always there it's just you don't see
them
in the front end as you wish
i mean i wouldn't say it that way i
don't think they should always be there
well
hold on we're talking about how to work
in dot m files themselves too
always there in the serialization well
we're saying siri we're acting we're
using all of this terminology as if
notebooks are the only way that people
write code
um you know editing a dot wl file in a
plain text editor
this stuff needs to work also i
understand that i understand that so i'm
saying that
in a plain text editor okay so that's
why
something like this convention could be
used in a plain text editor
and people could add that to the ide
plugins
that people make for wolfen language in
in those text editors
right yep and so so what i'm suggesting
is
some go ahead i'm just saying that that
partic
it's good if it has some text in there
like code formatter
because there might be linter directives
or other other things
okay i'm not a huge fan
of having a big blob of stuff there
because then
then if you see this thing in plain text
form
it's like saying let's paste the
notebooks
in you know in this form that would
clearly be undesirable right
well i mean at a bare minimum the word
format i think needs to appear though
i'm not agreeing with that i'm i'm
saying that
look look listen listen listen the point
is this
the you know this is the limiting case
where you're actually pasting exactly
you're copying exactly what the
structure is right including all
directives
right so what you want is something
where you don't have too heavy a thing
here
but where you can have something which
is somewhat human understandable there's
something there i also
will be good to have something that is
not absolutely implausible to type
i don't understand what's not readable
or typeable by the word format
whatever i i think we don't yet know
what these things
should sure sure but i mean i i don't
think it should pretend to be
too small i'm sorry one character like
that you know might be a bit too small
well we could use the exact same
convention that i used in snp
40 years ago and we could have comments
that mean something have colon colon at
the beginning of them
yeah um the notebooks i mean the package
editor
does do that for sections and code for
there is metadata using colon colon you
know
oh my gosh if you were to say that as a
dot m file right now
all of the sections would be saved the
co the section headers would be saved as
comments with that
and you know i i'm the one who
i believe i'm the one who invented that
and i didn't know about the smp
connection i just independently
came up with that amazing that's much
better because it's
it's a convention right there
um okay well anyway something like that
then which we've already used we've
already crossed the bridge of having
colon colon at the beginning of a
comment means something special
yeah okay so something like that
so john that mess up with the front end
or is it ignore things it doesn't
no it will ignore things it doesn't
understand
okay just that note that you sent
recently
oh it's just that that's just something
for your code assistant system
i mean by the way this this uh vertical
bar
dash greater than turning into the
function
character i'm really keen on that yeah i
i think that's great
let's get that as soon as john is that
something we can get quickly
uh you just want the ascii operator
yeah i just want the ascii operator to
turn into the function that's that's
uh that's pretty straightforward can
someone like etai
give a comment on it oh yeah i'd just
like to get an eye test
i think you died good comment on that i
think he did oh he did okay fine
good right i mean you know it's just
there is a slight concern about
precedence but i don't i think the
precedence
sorry no sorry etai commented on
the the conversation morphed into about
a pattern matching
a different conversation that's a
different conversation right
right so this here
yeah right so that doesn't do the right
thing
because that binds more tightly but this
yeah
very beautifully does do the right thing
that's great and i think it's very nice
and i mean we introduced this
years ago i know we introduced this
years and years and years ago
the ampersand these are proper lexical
lambda functions
well i understand but we introduced it
at a time before everybody understood
those
yeah yeah um but but now what is the
relative precedence of this
i mean low no no i understand but i'm
asking this question
this thing here oh boy
so this thing is lower precedence there
so this has to benefit
and there's no choice about this that's
the same as ampersand
yeah i understand well we should check
precedence but otherwise i think this is
going to be just fine
it's currently the same as equal and
everything
yeah so what does that mean so if i say
f equals this it'll work right
um well then the associate associativity
i'm not i don't remember
no no no no no no no we need to make
sure that this it's it's it's it's
sorry um i was fine looking at the
documentation and i didn't see what you
were doing on your screen so you want to
yes that that
i mean that works now yeah yeah and and
it works because it's right associative
it is the same as equal but it's right
associative yeah but so
if i say f um
uh x equals y then
yeah uh then once again right
associative
okay which is kind of nice actually
it is nice it seems like the right thing
yeah
yeah i'm sure we thought about it when
we put in function yeah i don't think i
participated in this but i
i approve
okay well this is quite lovely
i mean and and we should be able to have
things like this
um this will work just fine i mean this
is so what you'll be able to type is
vertical bar like this and that will
turn into
this and that will go x plus y there
and now beautiful how does that manage
to get the right that that's the right
oh that this is the precedence of equals
so that's good like every almost
everything is higher than it
you know i mean it does cause problems
but plus
that's not a problem yeah the only
practical operator that's uh uh
you know that's lower precedence
precedences
semicolon
well it's not really quite an operator
um
okay uh all right there's a comment here
from
remedies on apple they have a thing
called
text kit text and code formatter
it's comments about qt style sheets i
think that's related to previous things
it's going from ethan about training
gpt2 on
large uh source of code for autocomplete
we are very much
on that topic we have a bunch of stuff
on that
um and yeah
okay um i think that's everything
anything else for this meeting um when
do we get to see more stuff oh
we didn't finish this point here let me
just explain this
did did you understand what i was
talking about here yeah
well i mean just don't open that up just
evaluate that to get the animation
oh i just evaluate this yeah i mean it's
just a list of
it's just setting gift to a list of so
you can get that animation
um for people that care um just to show
what it would look like and
you know sublime that i was able to just
mock up quickly
um if you wanted to replace ampersand
with function and if you wanted to
replace ampersand with function and
rename hash
to a you know a variable all right so
listen this is the bane of lambda
calculus
and everything this is why you know this
is the
is the renaming of variables when you
have if you have a function
and you want to substitute into that
function
you see what i'm saying i mean in a
perfect world
there would be some kind of mechanism on
copy paste into a function
do you understand what i'm saying so let
me let me show you the scenario
right so what i'm talking about is if i
say hash plus 7
ampersand right that's a function right
now i have another function and i want
to say actually let me do it differently
here let me say
um f of x blank
slash at um
it's a good example here
slash at list okay great now what i want
to do
is i want to turn that f
into i want to turn the f into
g of hash slash at
blah blah blah okay
right that f is going to turn into g of
hash slash at whatever
oh and then i want to do this now wait a
minute this is going to work right
so if i do this
okay actually what i want to do let's
say okay so this is the problem
this is the problem case okay so i've
got this and now i'm going to paste this
in here
i'm going to paste this into the this is
going to become the f
see this is going to work because this
is going to work
but it's not going to work if i wanted
to get the outer hash here
exactly that outer hash if i wanted the
outer hash referenced
in here then i'm toast correct right
and so the question is can we detect
that case
and offer a rename
yes absolutely how do we detect that
case
well that's it's all lexical it's it's
it's easy
what do you mean no no no no but what
stephen's saying is
right it's hard to no
no it's not it's it's not possible well
knowing which one it binds to is not not
so straightforward no it's not so
straightforward but i suspect there's
some editing i mean you can't read your
mind with the
no wait a second wait a second there are
editing actions that make it clear what
the intent is
i think do you understand what i'm
saying
if you've got a function and you're now
going to add in another sub
function right see i've got this
function
here right and i'm going to add in
something which is another sub function
i'm going to change
you know the f or something into another
sub function then the question is when i
put down the hash there
what it should probably do in the sub
function when i put down the hash
it should say are you trying to refer to
yeah right if it sees there's an outer
function
yes with a hash in you could say are you
trying to refer to the hash and the
outer function
correct or not if you are trying to
refer to the hash and the outer function
you can refactor the code to use names
yep yep
yes and that's i mean with that cursor
right there
you it's easy to know that you're inside
two nested functions
yes so i mean that's
right so this case okay so let's think
about this case so in this case what it
wants to do
is to say this thing here should get
some code
you know attached thing that says
basically
is this ref trying to refer to the outer
hash
right i don't know how we want to say
that that isn't
well i don't know the other thing is
just convert it to function you know
right
right show show what this is
as a function function right in other
words
yeah yeah that's what we want to do and
maybe that's what you're already doing
show this as an autocomplete
in which this thing has been converted
to say
function x comma
g of x comma hash
ampersand slash at hash ampersand
right now why not convert everything to
the you know
bar arrow notation we could do that but
i'm not sure we want to do that we i
think
using function may be clearer yeah i
mean the syntax i mean that's the the
hard question is
where does the name x come from exactly
right exactly where does the name x come
it doesn't matter
well i don't think anyone of course but
a0
a1 a2 you know all right all right so
i've got a suggestion for this
okay
no my suggestion isn't good i was going
to say we could use formal variables
but that's not a good idea because
they're not easy to type i mean yes tom
you know it does the name does not
matter in a technical sense
but well it could matter it could matter
desperately
because it could collide with something
already there no no no
detecting working around collision is
easy to not have happen also that's fine
all right then let's do it
alphabetically starting with a
well fair fair enough fine okay i think
it's a non-stupid way to do it it's not
completely ridiculous to see
function with an a there a b c etc
i think that's the right default i mean
the other name is to have a suffix like
x1 x2 x3 that's just an alternative
no but that's not a good thing because
you know x could have been taken
you have no idea but you can keep adding
suffixes is what i'm saying don't worry
about running out of alphabetic letters
you know and if in a future with
multiple selection
we could uh you know end the operation
with
uh all instances of the variable
selected and then you could just
type whatever you want if you don't like
it
yes i understand that that's a nice idea
oh suggesting goes to the tcl route and
make an
up level of hash oh my god
oh no oh no that is going to get so
horrifying um
the problem i see with using that only
one letter is that
people usually have these as variables
in their code
so so it could be problematic too
we're not colliding like it might not be
abc you might just see you might just
have
ac as the suggestions yeah
look b i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what here's the compromise
okay guys here's the compromise it's an
auto complete
offer them two possibilities either the
alphabetic letter
or something like alpha you know greek
letters or something
okay if they're worried about collisions
go greek
yeah that's that's all feasible right
and then because just
it's it's a pair it's two things in
autocomplete
and um uh
okay suggestion about control f is a
keyboard shortcut for the function thing
not sure let's let's first of all just
do the the keyboard thing
the vertical bar dash greater than
replace all function unique variable
plus
space than wild cards
um the uh
okay um yeah i don't i don't think the
the upper level
uh function thing is it is a as a winner
um okay
all right i think one more comment here
smart global argument name refactoring
would be a nice
code completer function
that's an interesting idea say that
again
smart in other words let's say you go
into the left-hand side of a function
you've got f of x blank i mean i've
needed this many many times you've got f
of x blank colon equals blah blah blah
and i start editing this okay oh yeah
yeah
yeah offer to change it in all instances
on the right hand side
that's a good idea something that
understands lexical scoping
and can either be bounded by it or can
exclude it if it's you know
in uh you know in some cases you want to
exclude it because
you know you might be it might be a
child of you know the
the where you started yeah right
okay i need to get going workbench does
that workbench has a feature for doing
that
renaming all scope variables
um okay
sounds good for people uh following
these live streams we actually have
two more this afternoon this is um
clearly a new version is approaching
uh we have one on prediction and model
explanations
what on earth is that about oh
oh oh it's about machine learning
explainable machine learning
and then we have another about geometry
and graphics capabilities
um and uh
yeah great i'll see you sandra has one
more
comment here change your variable name
in module or with
yes that's another good idea that's
another good idea
you understand that idea same thing
it's a good idea yeah yeah yeah all
right
well we'll look forward to seeing some
of those code um
i mean this is this is in the category
of code edit well this is code
autocompletion
which i hope we're going to see soon
right
are we going to do a review of that soon
brenton i mean if you're asking about
front-end features
i mean the answer is no
because that requires front-end features
which we don't have for 12-2 is that
correct
if you're asking about sublime or other
editors the answer can start to be yes
i see okay all right fine okay but i
mean we first we need
to look what we're going to have is a
standard
for what all the various notifications
and so on are
in the code reformatter in the in the
code assistant system
and those things can then be ported to
the various different
you know the jungle of external editors
or eventually to the front end editor
and separately probably to the cloud
editor
right but the first thing we have to do
is agree on the standard
for how those different things are um
uh are set up well i'm not i'm not
following
i mean these external editors already do
a lot
that i'm i'm not wondering i'm not sure
if you're talking about something that
already exists
no no no i'm talking about let's say
that you're talking about renaming an
inner function variable yep okay there
is clearly going to be wording
and a standard for how that works that
is you click an inner function variable
it gives you a pull down you know the
the the
the the roman the greek versions you
know what i'm saying
and um uh and then it'll have some
perhaps some wording with that it'll do
something else for dealing with module
variables et cetera et cetera et cetera
we need a standard for how all those
things work that is each one of them
we need to define what is the ux that
goes with that particular action you're
meaning yeah
a ux standard yes and then
that ux has to be interpreted for each
of the various different editors
many probably in a very trivial way but
some of them it may be just plain text
that can
you know there may be meta things that
can be given where something is in
italics but it's not allowed to be
anything
beyond italics of the same font where it
can be a different font or it can have a
background color blah blah blah
right and so what we want to do is have
the gold standard for what this should
look like
and then in each particular editor
sublime whatever else
um you know we can
ratchet that down depending on what is
actually available in that editor
environment
does that make sense yes i mean
ratcheting down is a work
is a phrase but i mean so you know
default
coloring and sublime is a is a dark
background for
a dark theme okay fine fine so you're
saying it needs to be interpreted in a
variety of ways but yeah like things are
just different sometimes okay
fine fine okay so so okay so then what
you what we're saying is we need a gold
standard for what the thing
how the thing you know does its code
assistance right
and then we need interpretations for
each of these different deployment
channels
makes sense so we should assemble that
gold standard which should be what we
would use in notebooks and maybe we also
have dark mode notebooks
which can cover that particular issue um
and uh you know so so we're really good
to see
that collection of standards for how
we're doing those things
make sense even if they are not
instantly
available in all the environments but we
need to
have the design of those standards
okay good stuff guys all right
thanks a lot and thank you for um um
uh uh for all those things
thanks for the comments on live stream
and so on
and uh for those interested it looks
like it's only a little bit more than an
hour before we have another
live stream coming up okay see y'all
soon